what is the origin of intelligence is it
uh
that we started
cooking meat over fire
is it that we somehow figured out that
we could be very powerful we start
collaborating so cooperation between
um our ancestors
so that we can overthrow the alpha male
uh what is it richard i talked to
richard ranham who thinks we're all just
beta males who figured out how to
collaborate to defeat the one the the
dictator the authoritarian alpha male
um that controlled the tribe um is there
other explanation did was there um 2001
space type of monolith yeah that came
down to earth well i i think um i think
all of those things you suggest for good
candidates fire and and and cooking
right so that's clearly important for
energy you know energy efficiency yeah
cooking our meat and then and then being
able to to to be more efficient about
eating it and getting it consuming the
energy um i think that's huge and then
utilizing fire and tools i think you're
right about the the tribal cooperation
aspects and probably language as part of
that yes um because probably that's what
allowed us to out-compete neanderthals
and and perhaps less cooperative species
so um so that may be the case
tool-making spears axes
i think that let us i mean i think it's
pretty clear now that humans were
responsible for a lot of the extinctions
of megafauna um especially in
the americas when humans arrived so uh
you can imagine once you discover tool
usage how powerful that would have been
and how scary for animals so i think all
of those could have been explanations
for it you know the interesting thing is
that it's a bit like general
intelligence too is it's very costly to
begin with to have a brain uh and
especially a general purpose brain
rather than a special purpose one
because the amount of energy our brains
use i think it's like 20 of the body's
energy and it's it's massive and when
you're thinking chess one of the funny
things that that we we used to say is
this as much as a racing driver uses for
a whole you know formula one race you're
just playing a game of you know serious
high-level chess which you know you
wouldn't think just sitting there um
because the brain's using so much uh uh
energy so in order for an animal an
organism to justify that there has to be
uh a huge payoff and the problem with
with half a brain or half you know
intelligence saying iqs of you know
of like a monkey brain it's
it's not clear you can justify that
evolutionary until you get to the human
level brain and so but how do you how do
you do that jump it's very difficult
which is why i think it's only been done
once from the sort of specialized brains
that you see in animals to this sort of
general purpose chewing powerful brains
that humans have um
and which allows us to invent the modern
modern world um and uh you know it takes
a lot to to cross that barrier and i
think we've seen the same with ai
systems which is that uh maybe until
very recently it's always been easier to
craft a specific solution to a problem
like chess than it has been to build a
general learning system that could
potentially do many things because
initially
that system will be way worse than less
efficient than the specialized system
you